Europe is leading one of the most
important space travel efforts of this
century it's a mission called remove
debris and if all goes according to plan
it could save the future of space travel
as we know it the objective of remove
debris is just that demonstrate how we
could remove space debris that's
cluttering up Earth's orbit including
pieces of used up Rockets and retired
satellites even though you can't see it
from the ground there are more than half
a million chunks of space trash flying
around our planet and most of it is
concentrated in low-earth orbit where it
whips around at 28,000 kilometres an
hour fast enough to fly from LA to
London in just 19 minutes but here's the
trouble with that low Earth orbit is our
front door to the universe to get
anywhere in space whether it's the
International Space Station Mars or
beyond we have to cross that threshold
first but if you have a bunch of garbage
blocking your path it's gonna be
difficult even worse experts like
astrophysicist Donald Kessler fear that
just one collision between two large
objects could seal up that opening
forever because it would set off a chain
reaction one collision after another
after another which could produce
thousands of additional pieces of debris
this domino effect is called the Kessler
syndrome after Donald Kessler himself
and it predicts that low-earth orbit
could become littered with space trash
making it too dangerous for spacecraft
to fly through or also reduce their
lifespans because of collisions
that's where Europe's remove debris
mission comes in in 2018 it successfully
tested the first of four stages of its
trash cleanup technology and it looked
like this this is not an illustration
this is actually happening in space
that's a net about the size of a large
dining room table cloth and snaring a
small spacecraft that the mission
implanted for the experiment now this
was just the first of what will
hopefully be many more tests because in
the future we're gonna need a bigger net
at the end of the day the the final goal
is to be able to capture a very large
target so possibly one of the target
that has been mentioned as a potential
one is in old satellite and this app and
it is maybe the size of a bus scientists
have been proposing ways to clean up
space trunks since the early 90s they've
thought of everything from lasers to
robotic claws but this is the first time
any concept has actually been tested in
space the team hopes to test its other
three technologies as well which involve
a harpoon for spearing the trash a
navigation system for analyzing the
trash the size distance and rotation and
a sail for slowing the trash down so it
can re-enter and burn up in Earth's
atmosphere but all this technology isn't
the reason this mission has come closer
than any before it everybody agrees that
to remove some of this debris is the
right thing to do but clearly the issue
is going to be you know the cost the
remove debris project has cost fifteen
million euro or about seventeen million
US dollars
the current mission was sponsored by the
European community and again we had you
know 10 partners working on this project
and overall the cost of this project was
about you know 15 millions when you are
going to do this kind of mission for
real the cost will be higher and so I
think the values you know stakeholders
around the world have to get together
and and decide how such mission could be
funded we are talking about not just you
know the UK or maybe NASA but also China
you know Russia and so on the problem is
again who is going to pay for it so
Europe has taken the lead rest of the
world it's your turn now
you
[Music]